a lack of confidence in zimbabwe's
dollar and soaring inflation is taking a
toll on its people the central bank is
more than doubling interest rates from
80 to 200 from july the first an attempt
to rein in inflation the finance
minister hopes to boost market
confidence saying other currencies will
still be used for the next five years
the government is getting stated this in
its intention of maintaining a
multi-current system based on the dual
use of the us dollar and this mobile
dollar in the main however
the market's
lack of confidence in the multi-current
systems
is is causing us challenges
and i want to assure you that this
multi-current system is here to stay
into the foreseeable future
inflation reached more than 191 percent
in june that's made life even harder for
millions of people
previous attempts by the government to
stop a collapse of zimbabwe's currency
included a 10-day ban on bank lending
economists here are divided on whether
that worked officials say they'll now
introduce gold coins into the market for
individuals to store value but some
economists say this may not be practical
49 percent of the population in extreme
poverty
7.9 million people who cannot live on a
dollar 90 cents a day they can even go
to bed without eating
you have 70 percent of the raw
population in profit
so who is going to buy the gold coins
government officials also plan to reduce
taxes on fuel to curb price increases as
well as increased allowances for health
workers and civil servants after unions
rejected a one hundred percent wage
increase
but with soaring inflation this may do
little to help people facing a rising
cost of living haru mutasa al jazeera